I like this new wave of feminine crime
fiction writers who are feminist but not
in the upg politically correct way that
feminism is an authentic feminism.
You know,
they don't have this pattern ising
attitude.
Like,
you know,
women,
women should always be passive victims
and so on.
But even maybe now I will say something
for rich,
maybe I not be popular here even better
than how she called Gillian Flynn or
what is an Irish girl called Tana
French?
A theories of crime fiction taking place
in Dublin with more or less the same
spirit,
the same attitude.
A kind of a,
if I have to invent some stupid title,
a kind of a dark New York feminist,
uh,
crime thrillers.
But know of the,
of the movie that I recently saw,
there is a problem.
Often a movie attracts me,
not attract me,
but gives me to think intellectually,
but I don't really like it.
Uh,
as a movie for example,
uh,
the one,
her with your,
when you know,
uh,
in the field at the end,
she is the hero together with the girl,
I think she's called amy,
but they are both abandoned by their
machines.
The big enigma here is,
and this is what always attracted me,
and this is I think what my mentor in
theory,
French tracker and list Jacques Lacan in
this,
that in his crazy fees is there is no
sexual relationship,
which means we are never alone.
Me and my partner,
there has to be a third element as
fantasy scene,
an intruder.
It's only through that mediation of a
third element here in her,
their operating systems that sex
functions.
And then I started to think about other
variations of this.
Like for example,
a perfect there intelligently mate,
20 years old,
British publicity for beer,
which is a var,
wonderful,
ironic repetition of a old fairy tale
motive.
You know,
a young girl walks by a stream,
she's a frog.
And of course that's what you do in
fairy tales.
She picks up and kisses the frog and the
frog into a prince charming young man.
But then the publicity goes on.
The charming Yank man looks at her,
kisses her and she turns into a can of
beer.
You know,
like that's what he really wanted,
you know,
and then I found here in the states,
and similar but inverted versions,
some pretty disgusting mentally
publicity for Taco Bell publicity for
something called Casa Ardito,
which is Kisa Delia in Burrito
combination of the two.
And it's presented in such an obscene
way that if you combine the two,
it's really like a penis in wrapped by a
vagina.
But if,
how is the publicity spot down here?
Uh,
a young guy and the girl see during
lunch break at a table,
one has guess ideally at the other
Burrito and they look at each other and
then you see each person's dream boy
looks at her and imageries the future.
They start to talk,
they get married,
have children,
then she looks at him,
approach him in her dream and take his
piece of Burrito or whatever.
Uh,
what apps keep apps that she gets a kind
of a bisexual completing and just makes
a sign and he disappears.
You know,
it's similar to that word beer,
but what I think is the deep enigma
behind all this.
Why do we never get just a couple?
Why it always has to be some intruders
and the best Hollywood version of this,
I ask all the viewers
who are watching us now to to download,
you can download it for free.
It's an American classic movies,
Preston Sturgis Lady Eve,
where you have the ultimate marriage
proposal scene.
You have a Henry Fonda and Barbara
stanwyck and a horse standing behind
them and the horse's head is always
intruding and so on and so on.
That is the mystery of sex.
It's never too,
you always need something and imagined
gaze,
an element intruding and so on.
And so on.